turning now overseas to an amazing
explosion of public anger in sri lanka
the island country off the southern
coast of
india it has forced the president and
prime minister to resign there as tens
of thousands of protesters occupied the
homes the bedrooms even the bathrooms of
two leaders in that country in the
capital city of colombo the country's
economy has collapsed it's run out of
food and fuel and medicine and other
essential supplies and as elizabeth
palmer reports the capital is now in
chaos
by saturday the pressure on the
government was overwhelming with tens of
thousands protesting outside the
presidential headquarters
and then as word spread that the
president had gone
a crowd surged into gautabaya
rajapaska's private residence and were
amazed
whole families toured the opulence
some tried out his private gym others
took a dip in the presidential pool
while security services stood back and
watched
the mood was festive
unlike the night before when police
fired tear gas
to disperse crowds who'd set fire to the
house of the prime minister
anger has been building over fuel
shortages and a collapsed economy thanks
in part to corruption and incompetence
but also to covet which shut down
tourism sri lanka's main source of
income
the protesters say they're going nowhere
until they're sure the president has
stepped down supposedly on wednesday
though there's been no word from the man
himself
apart from the fire the atmosphere has
remained largely peaceful and now
politicians are trying to build a
cross-party coalition to take power and
come to grips with the economic mess
vlad
liz thank you very much